the mcrib was first introduced in 1981
it quickly amassed a cult-like following
and it's been in and out of mcdonald's
ever since every time it's released
people go crazy for it
i had to make rib one time years ago and
i loved it but i've been craving that
sweet tangy flavor ever since
but unfortunately mcdonald's only brings
it out when they feel like it what if
you could have the mcrib
anytime anywhere i'm nicki giovanni and
today
i'm going to be recreating the mcrib
the mcrib is super simple it's just
ground pork in the shape of a rib
on a hoagie roll with a couple of
pickles and a couple pieces of onion the
last time i had to make herb was
many years ago and i haven't seen
mcdonald's carrying it since but i
remember how delicious it was it had
that
amazing aspect of ribs coupled with that
kind of sweet tangy delicious sauce that
they make to go along with it
today i'm gonna press some pork into the
shape of rib to try to replicate that
rib like look of a mcgrib sandwich and
then i'm going to go on to make that
sweet tangy
barbecuey honey like sauce finally i've
got my friend dylan a former mcdonald's
employee coming by to determine if my
version
looks and most importantly tastes like
the classic mcrib
all right so i'll start by taking my
ground pork here
just have to season my pork up to try to
give that mcrib flavor
i know that it starts off with some
simple ground pork i'll add a little bit
of garlic powder followed by a teeny bit
of onion powder
a little bit of salt and a touch of
pepper
and i think that's all the seasoning i
need to kind of get that
mcgrub taste because most of that flavor
is going to come from the sauce that i
paint over the top of it and i'll
quickly mix this up just to really get
that flavor
inside and all over the meat actually
smells really good but this bowl is so
hot from the uh
dishwasher that it's like cooking the
meat already that's fine so now i'll
take my sheet tray
and i'm gonna press it into that mcrib
shape that we're looking for
so i just have to do something that
looks relatively like
a rib mcdonald's actually does a really
good job with that i'm basically just
gonna press them down on this tray
i'm gonna try to get in that general
size shape of this bulky roll so
i'm going to make it a little bit longer
i think i need a little bit more meat on
that
to me it's a very strange concept trying
to shape this ground meat
back into the original form before you
actually ground it but
i also kind of like it this is about the
same size now as my bulky roll
it's just pretty much perfect and i know
the meat's gonna shrink a little bit
after it cooks so i can make it even a
little bit longer
i'm just gonna go ahead and take my
finger and just make these big sort of
rib like shapes that mcdonald's has
one two i wish i had the machine that
does this that would be really helpful
so i'm just gonna toss these in the oven
at 425 for a couple minutes
and then come back and put my glaze on
for the sauce i'm just gonna mix
together a bunch of different
ingredients that i think will sort of
perfectly replicate microbe sauce i'm
actually going to go ahead and
this will be a good little trick here
for some acid and i'll use a little bit
of my dill pickle juice
and then we'll go with a little bit of
molasses for those who don't know
molasses is burnt
sugar so basically i'm gonna get a
little bit of that caramelized
or extra caramelized sugar flavor in
there and then
sort of similar molasses i'll get a
little bit
of barbecue sauce that is gonna be where
most of that mcgrib sauce comes from
i'll also want to kind of
still balance it out with a little bit
of salt in there and maybe just a touch
of pepper because there's already some
pepper in that barbecue so
not too much although a little bit of
garlic powder in there as well
and then just sort of balance all that
sort of sour i want a little bit of
sweet so
i'm gonna add just a tiny bit of sugar
just a sort of splash of that
and when i put that on the microphone
and bake it it'll hopefully caramelize
and give an even better flavor to this
whole thing and then just to give a
little bit more acid because it's that
tangy sweet sauce we're going
for i'm going to go ahead and cut a
lemon and then i'll squeeze that
right over my hand here and get a little
bit of that juice in there
keep in mind i want the sauce to kind of
be able to paint really easily over the
top of the mcrib and not fall off when i
bake it
so i want to go for a consistency that's
not too watery i'll go ahead and just
mix that up
and see what i come up with here that
looks really good and it smells even
better
give that just a little quick taste
because you should always taste and
season when you can
that's really really good so this
is awesome it's crackling and popping it
smells incredible
these actually look a little bit like
ribs and if i even paint off the bubbles
that are forming on here this one looks
exactly like the mcrib
this one is a little on the chubbier
side so now i'm going to just paint this
sauce right over the top of our mcribs
now is when i want to get even more
flavor on those and i'll put it back in
the oven to bake them
just to sort of caramelize it and really
solidify kind of suck
in that flavor into the microbe itself
so now i'm going to quickly toast my
bread and that's just pretty easy
i'm just going to cut these hoagie rolls
almost all the way through
and then i'll be able to bend them open
just enough that i can lay it flat
and just get a little bit of that golden
brown toasting that mcdonald's has for
their mcribs
let me go ahead and just put my bulky
roll right down on there
so my hoagie roll is nice and toasted
right in the middle there and that's
exactly what i want
so my ribs look perfect
again there's still one that to me looks
exactly right on the mark which i'm
super excited about i'm just about ready
to assemble my sandwich all i have to do
is a little bit of knife work here since
i want these sort of thin cuts that they
have on the real mcgrib
i'm just going to go right down the line
and just cut
these nice little strips of onion
that'll come out to be like
this i got these perfect little furrows
of onion that i'm gonna work with here
and last but not least i have my dill
pickle
really thin slices right down the side
of this
like super flimsy thin cuts i like thin
cuts of pickles on different things
because
i just don't like that much of a really
acidic pickley bite and we already have
enough acid
in our sauce so to put this all together
i'll put my sandwich down on the table
here and i want to take my mcrib that
actually looks
nice and i'll lay that right down in the
bottom of the hoagie roll fits super
well i think i want a little bit more
sauce
because i think they just really load it
up with sauce so i'll put a
light tiny sort of glaze this is our
third coating of seasoning and then last
but not least just a couple
onions and pickles so i don't want to
overload us with onion
followed by just another light coating
of our pickles
and i think that's it i think we've
nailed the mcgrip i think they do a
slightly better job you know making
those little rib bits
shut out on the edges to have where the
bones would be but
you know i'm actually really happy with
what i've done here i've also done a
really pretty job layering out my
pickles to me this looks extremely
appetizing it smells
even better
yeah this is a mcrib i remember
wow that's incredible the bun is
perfectly toasted the sauce incredible
the pickles are perfect
but nick i think you should have put a
little more sauce
because it would have been a tad better
i'm gonna take this with me
i'm definitely pumped that the
mcdonald's expert
dylan loved my sandwich granted i think
there's a couple little things i could
do next time to make this even more
like the mcdonald's mcgrib mainly i
think that has to do with the quantity
of sauce i'd also love to shape it a
little bit better and kind of have those
ribs shutting out a tiny bit more
and if i do that i think i've nailed the
macro
[Music]
you